the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
as you all know i have been writing my
own version of game of thrones season 9.
these are some things i thought could
happen if hbo ever decided to make
another season of the show
one thing i realized while writing this
season is it's not as easy as it seems
in fact it's actually kind of difficult
i am still searching for that right
balance of making nearly every scene
either
meaningful interesting or at the very
least entertaining
i've also been trying to get a new
episode out each week which means i
don't have very much time to think of
great ideas
while also having them make sense based
on what we already know about this story
and what we know about each
individual character now i'm sure most
of you don't care about any of the
behind the scenes stuff
i guess i just wanted to say this has
been harder than i thought it would be
so that's why the videos may not get
released as fast as you like
now let's get into the video this is my
version of game of thrones season 9
episode 4
which i have named the raven shall we
begin
in the opening scene we are back in the
city streets of king's landing
the sun is just now beginning to set as
we see wagons full of new arrivals
entering the city
king's landing is obviously still in
shambles but now that everyone believes
things are stable in westeros again
they're starting to travel to the
different kingdoms the capital of
westeros is starting to look alive again
although it does still need a lot of
work we then begin to follow one of the
wagons down the street
there are men and women all over working
on making king's landing a thriving city
like it once was
there are men lifting heavy stones off
the ground there are women sweeping the
street
shaking the dust out of their rugs as
well as fixing up some of the bait shops
warehouses and small markets the scent
of raw sewage
and baked bread is in the air the wagon
stops in front of a building
where a few men are standing outside
laughing and drinking their wine
a man and woman get out of their wagon
before they walk inside
there are half naked women dancing and
sitting in the laps of a few men
who are seated around the table where
drinks are being served
there's also a few young men lifting a
new barrel of veil
there's a woman sitting alone fixing her
hair
it looks like everyone is enjoying
themselves we suddenly hear a voice that
sounds familiar
in the back of the room there's three
men sitting at a small table
drinking and sharing their war stories
one of the men is brawn
the other men sitting with him are from
the stark's household guard
whose sons are left behind for her
brother bran as brawn drinks his ale
one of the stark men says so sir brown
of the blackwater
lord of high garden or whatever your
name is these days
what's it like sitting on the king's
small council well says braun
i imagine it's about as boring as it is
working for the stark's household guard
most of my days are spent sitting around
wondering how much longer i can stay in
this city
i have my own castle now gentlemen why
would i want to stay in this godforsaken
hellhole
the stark man says really you're not
fond of the capital
let me ask you something else how did
someone like you end up in that position
anyway
the same way i became bruno the black
water says braun
eventually the lannisters do pay their
debts
they all begin laughing brawn then says
why do you keep asking so many questions
anyway the stark man says
i have worked for house stark for many
years yet i can't figure out why one of
ned stark's children would allow you
on their small council this is when
braun stops smiling
he sits down his drink stares hard at
the man then says
you should watch your mouth i like
drinking with you fellas but don't let
my new fancy clothes and my new fancy
titles fool you
besides i don't think king bran does
much thinking about me anyway
in fact i'm not sure he does much
thinking at all
i like him i really do but there's
something strange about that boy
what do you expect says the start guard
most of his family is dead
he has been alphy on the wall surrounded
by white walkers
he has seen things no kid should ever
see is that right says brawn
like what all of my family is dead
i've been out beyond the wall it wasn't
that scary
i saw a man die a slow death when i was
only 5 years old
what of it brawn finishes his drink then
slams it down
when he stands up he stumbles a little
bit before walking away
he mutters something under his breath
right as he reaches the door
after he walks out of the inn we watch
him as he heads back down the street
in the direction of the red keep right
before the scene ends we see a raven
land on the wagon that's sitting right
out front
in the next scene of this episode we are
back in the north somewhere near
winterfell deep beneath the ground
we are following three men as they walk
further and further into the darkness
searching for an end we should start
back says one of the younger star
guardsmen
i don't think this will ever end we have
already been walking down here for
several days
if we don't find something soon we will
have to start rationing out the food
the young star guardsman looks very
nervous as if he can send something is
down here with them
six days they had been walking north and
then northwest and then north again
farther and farther from winterfell's
crypt each day had been worse than the
day before
the more they walk the colder and darker
it gets the ground is still frozen
the white and red roots of the weirwood
are still running along the ceiling
although they look more like the veins
inside a man's arm
does the darkness frighten you says the
commander of the stark guardsman
there's nothing down here except for the
icicles the darkness and one scared
boy you can run back to winterfell if
you'd like
but your grace has given us orders we
are not to stop until we find the exit
the three men keep moving forward into
the unknown
as their light bounces off the wall we
can see the ice crystals glistening all
over the ground
as well as the walls and the ceiling
there is a red
sappy-like substance dripping down from
the roots of the weirwood
suddenly all three of the stark
guardsmen stop when they notice
something ahead
the underground passage opens up into
what looks like a cave
it almost looks like the three-eyed
ravens cave the only difference is there
aren't any bones in this one
there isn't any weirwood thrones in this
one either the men walk in a little
further
as they hold up their lights we can see
that the cave
is now connected to seven different
passageways all heading in different
directions
the men look at each other in disbelief
in a low
frightened voice the young stark
guardsman says what do we do now
how will we know which way to go we
won't says the commander
we will just keep moving forward and if
it's a dead end we will try another one
the men move on straight ahead as their
lights fade away into the black abyss
in the following scene we go back out
beyond the wall
jon snow the wildling woman and torm and
giant spain are walking back outside of
the three-eyed ravens cave
all of the other wildlings are at their
campsite gathered around the fire
right out front the wildlings begin to
stand up
as they see them finally walking back
out of the cave
when they reach the fire tormund
addresses all of them by saying
this is where we will have to go our
separate ways now
all of you can stay here if you want or
you can even make shelter inside the
cave
but john and i will be leaving to go
south
south i thought you weren't allowed in
the south says one of the other
wildlings
well it is complicated says john i had
no intentions of ever riding south again
but my family needs me they will have to
understand
i can't say that i'm sad to see you go
says the wildling man
he smiles then gives giants bane a hug
he then shakes jon's hand before walking
back over by the fire
john walks over to the wildling woman
who helped him find the cave
he says i never did thank you for
helping me it's alright says the
wildling woman
if things go your way in the south i
guess i should be thanking you
john smiles and says i never did get
your name
the wildling woman walks over near him
when she is standing in front of john
she holds out her hand then says my name
is val
john shakes her hand and says thank you
val
she smiles and says i wish you good
fortune before walking away
john watches as she sits back down by
the fire deep down he doesn't want to
leave
but he knows he has to that's when jon
feels a hard and heavy hand
slap him across the back right as
tormund says are you ready snow
she will be here when you get back let's
go
jon nods his head in agreement then
follows him back inside the three at
raven's cave
they follow the roots of the weirwood
further and further down
until they're deep below the ground
again there are even more ravens than
before
sitting on the skull scattered across
the cave floor
the sound of rushing water can be heard
below there is flickering light bouncing
off the cave walls just ahead
when they walk back inside the cavernous
chamber jon sees helen reed running his
fingers through ghost's thick white fur
the dire wolf's eyes are glowing red
like fresh blood
helen reed stands up then walks away
after jon takes several more steps he
suddenly stops in his tracks
when he notices something is different
right in front of them is where the
children of the forest are sitting in
their weirwood thrones
only now one of them is gone the child
of the forest who was sitting in the
middle is no longer there this startles
jon
they look so old and interwoven with the
branches he did not think they could
leave
let alone walk helen reed fades away
into the shadows behind the weirwood
thrones
jon looks around the cave but he doesn't
see anyone else there
where did he go says john why would he
leave now
the two remaining children of the forest
don't say anything at all
they only stare at jon their great
golden cat's eyes look as if they're
full of wisdom
deeper than the roots of the weirwood
that surrounds them helen reed reemerges
from the shadows
he walks over by jon snow looks him
right in the eyes
then says you will not see him again he
has gone from here jon snow
helen reed then hands something to john
he had a weirwood bow in his hands
carved with a dozen faces inside the
bowl is a white paste
thick and heavy it has dark red veins
running through it
you must eat this said halland he handed
john a wooden spoon
john looked at the bowl uncertainly what
is it says john
it's made of weirwood seeds said one of
the children of the forest
something about the look of it made jon
feel sick the red veins were only
wherewood sappy thought
but under the light they looked
remarkably like blood he dipped the
spoon down into the substance then
hesitated
why are you giving me this ass john i'm
not hungry
the child of the force says you have the
blood of the first men
as well as the blood of the dragon jon
snow the weirwood seeds will help awaken
the gifts inside you
the gifts you did not know you have we
only knew one other man who had the
blood of the first men and the blood of
the dragon
that man was lord brendan rivers who sat
in the weirwood throne above us
he was once the lord commander at castle
black just like you
but then he came to us and he became
something so much more
you must eat it jon snow you will need
it for your journey that lies ahead
john ate it it was bitter the first
spoonful was the hardest to get down
he almost wretched it right back up the
second spoonful was better
the third was almost sweet the rest he
spooned up eagerly
it actually tasted of honey of new
fallen snow
of cinnamon and other flavors he loved
the empty bowl slipped right from his
fingers and clattered on the cavern
floor
ghosts ran over then licked what was
left in the bottom of the bowl
i don't feel any different said john
what happens next
now we will leave says helen reed
he walks back behind the wherewit
thrones again when he reemerges
he has something else in his hands
wrapped under a fur blanket
john notices that whatever it is it has
a strap around it
allowing helen reed to sling the object
over his shoulder
when helen is done he looks at them and
says let's go
john and tormund begin to follow him out
of the cavernous chamber
right before they walk out one of the
children of the forest says one last
thing
do not go back above ground jon snow
stay in the cave
then follow the roots of the weirwood
until you get further south
we do not need horses down here our way
is faster
jon is befuddled he knew the cave went
far into the ground
but he did not know it went south i will
show you the way
says helen reed ghost runs off in front
of them
he moves through the shadows as if he
knows where to go
he moves through the darkness as if he
has been this way before
the scene ends as we watch the men
follow behind the direwolf
before they begin fading away into the
dark abyss
in the following scene we are back out
at sea the sails of house stark are high
in the sky
under the light of the sun the morning
air is hazy from the smoke of the
cockfires
as a dozen men set down to break their
fast beneath the banners of the great
house of winterfell
arya stark emerges from below she walks
back out onto the main
deck then takes in a long deep breath of
that sweet morning error
she goes over to where the men are
sitting down having their food
arya grabs a fistful of baked bread
before she stood over by the rail
ian looked out across the sea at some
southern lands she has never been
there are several small islands near the
horizon
from here it almost looks beautiful the
deep blue sea was glistening from the
sun shining down
it is a gorgeous day but it looks like
there is a storm ahead
just above the small islands that set
off in the distance
she stands there for a few moments
looking at all of her surroundings
as she nibbles on the food that's when
arya is interrupted when she hears the
sound of a seagull
as it lands on the rail of the ship she
breaks off some of her bread
then throws it up into the sky the
seagull leaps off the rail
opens its mouth wide then snatches the
bread out of the sky
arya smiles then throws the rest of her
bread onto
the deck as she begins walking away
another sound is heard
only this one is from above when arya
looks up
a raven lands on the enormous sail of
the ship then it let out another loud
shriek
that's when arya notices there is
something different about this raven
she watches as the raven's eyes go from
black to white
then back to black again arya suddenly
has a feeling of dread wash over her
it's as if the raven is looking right
through her arya slowly walks away
until she vanishes below the deck it's
only a few moments later when she
re-emerges
only now she has a bow and arrow in her
hand arya watches the raven
as she walks back over by the railing
its eyes go from black to white then
back to black again
arya notches one of her arrows then
draws the string back hard
she holds the arrow back as she also
holds her breath
the raven's white eyes are looking right
at her almost as if it's challenging her
to let the arrow fly
that's when arya lets it loose the arrow
slices right through the morning air
but it misses by only a few inches the
raven did not move
arya grabs another arrow notches it then
draws it back as far as she can
she looks over at the stark banner
flapping in the wind waiting only a few
seconds for it to be in her favor
the moment she releases the string the
raven takes flight from the sail
arya watches as her arrow hits nothing
but the sky before falling into the sea
below
the raven lets out another loud shriek
as it circles above
one of the men who is sitting at the
table says i'm sorry my lady
you almost had it arya doesn't respond
she walks back across the ship
over to where the captain is standing at
his wheel
when he sees that arya is approaching he
bows his head then says
good morning my lady i see you were
sharpening your skills at archery
it's not so easy when a ship is rocking
back and forth beneath you
arya says do you know where we are the
captain smiles and says
well of course my lady i would not be a
very good captain if i did not
he holds out his finger motioning in
front of him those small group of
islands you see in the distance are the
step stones my lady
now if you look over here to the west
can you see that speck of land near the
horizon
yes i do says arya well you're now
looking at dorne my lady
thank you cesaria she looks back up into
the sky
right as the captain begins saying
something else but arya doesn't hear him
she now has all of her focus on the
raven that is still following them from
above
arya watches it for a few more seconds
before cutting off the captain's story
arya says i have changed my mind i don't
think i will go to king's landing
confused the captain says what do you
mean my lady
where will you have me go instead this
scene ends right after arya says
i must go to storm's end first in the
next scene
we are back in the north inside the
castle of hell stark
sansa is sitting in what was once her
father's high seat
in the great hall of winterfell maester
walcan is seated at her right
beside her on sansa's left the seat is
empty
a large fire is burning inside the
hearth the gray-granite stone walls
inside the great hall
were draped without stark's banners once
again the air is hazy from the smoke
and heavy from the smell of roasted meat
and fresh baked bread
there is a bard running his fingers
along the strings of a high heart
while reciting the words from some
ballad sansa once knew
sansa smiles as she looks around
listening to the sounds of laughter
and a hundred different drunken
conversations it is so noisy that it was
hard to hear anyone who wasn't right
beside you
eight long rows of tables filled
winterfell's great hall
four on each side of the center aisle
lords and ladies of the north were
crowded shoulder to shoulder
on the benches in front of her right as
sansa is standing up
all of the noise inside winterfell falls
silent as everyone watches
and waits for their queen to speak this
is when we will see a man walk over and
hand a letter to the maester sansa
raises her drink in the air
then says first i just want to thank all
of you for joining me for this feast
i welcome you all to our fires and offer
you meat
and mead in honor of our friendship it
honestly warms my heart to see this
hall filled with all of the northern
uniforms yet again
my father eddard stark always said a
lord needs to dine with his men
if he ever hopes to keep them know the
men who follow you
and make sure they know you don't ask
your men
to die for a stranger with that being
said
i must apologize however because some of
you nearly died for daenerys targaryen
i want to make it known here and now the
north is independent
like it should have always been the only
time i will ever ask any of you to fight
for me
is so that we can keep it that way
everyone begin slamming their cups down
against the table
as they yell stark stark stark
winterfell winterfell winterfell sansa
smiles
and then she raises her drink again
silencing the great hall
my lords and ladies if you would look
beside me you will see i have left an
empty seat
it was left this way for a reason my
father always had an extra seat set at
his own table
and every day a different man would join
him so my father could know him
and he could know my father i am asking
each of you to do the same
sonza then leans over and asks the
maester what does the letter say is it
from my brother bran
as he shakes his head the maester says
know your grace
i still have not received any word from
king's landing
this makes sansa very angry then
something is wrong says sansa
our ravens have went south yet none of
them have come
back she stands up again and says before
any of you join me
on this evening first i would like to
speak with our master of horse
we see a stick thin man with brown hair
and a brown beard
walking up to the main table he then
sits down next to sansa
your grace how may i be of service says
winterfell's master of horse
this scene ends right after santa says i
want you to have horses ready when the
feast is
over i will be sending some of my men
south
in the next scene we go back across the
narrow sea in the city of volantis
daenerys kinvara and the other
high-ranking members of her lore
are all inside the great hall of the red
temple we see a man
who is dressed in a red silk robe walk
across the great hall
until he is standing right before dany
holding in his hands is a wooden box
that has the burning heart carved into
its lid
he gives it to daenerys then says this
is a gift from the lord of light
it will help you against the darkness
wear this daenerys stormborn
and it shall be your shield against the
great other when daenerys opens the box
she can see there is a necklace laying
on a scarlet robe of her own
the necklace has a great red ruby just
like the one melisandre
and canvara wore around their throats as
daenerys lays it around her neck
the great red ruby starts to glisten as
if it were a fire
then she unfolds her new robe and throws
it over her shoulders
in red and gold stitching it has the
burning heart of velour on the front of
it
across its back it has the three-headed
dragon of house targaryen
thank you says daenerys kanvara now
grabs danny's hand
then looks in her eyes and says you are
the one who was promised daenerys
stormborn
from the great fires overlor you have
been reborn
and you will remake the world you no
longer have a large army
like you once had you no longer have
three dragons like you once had
yet still we must leave volantis soon
every day the great other grows stronger
but so shall we
daenerys stormborn what do you mean we
says daenerys you will not succeed if we
sent you back to westeros alone says
kinvara
we all must make our sacrifices we will
be coming with you
as well as our fiery hand your dragon
and our ships are waiting for us outside
where will we go first
daenerys wants to know we will go to
harrenhal says canvara
jon snow is already on his way there now
the sound of jon's name made daenerys
nervous
but the thought of seeing him again also
made her very angry
remember what i said daenerys stormborn
you and jon snow will need each other
you will not allow yourself to be lost
again the scene ends as the red ruby on
dany's throat begins to glow
even brighter than before in the
following scene
we go back out beyond the wall we're
following jon
tormund ghost and helen reed as they
make their way
south through the underground system
below the threat raven's cave
they're now walking through a much
smaller passageway
there are no longer bones all over the
ground but you can still see the roots
of the werewood running along the
ceiling
like the veins in a man's body ghost is
several feet in front of them leading
the way
john looks over at helen reed who is
readjusting the large item that's on his
back
then says we have a very long walk ahead
of us my lord
do you mind if i ask you some questions
not at all says helen reed
that's one of the reasons why i'm here
jon snow ask me whatever you'd like
before he says anything john thinks back
on what was said
by the children of the forest he thinks
about bran
and all the strange things he said as
well finally
john says if my brother bran is not the
same anymore
then how can i believe anything he said
you also said bran is getting influenced
or even manipulated by the children in
the south
everything he has said may have been a
lie
john looks back over at helen reed you
said you were there the day i was born
what actually happened i was there the
day you were born says helen reed but i
was also there the day your father met
your mother
during the year of the fall spring there
was a great tournament held at the
castle of harrenhal
almost everyone of significance was
there that day
yet when the jousting began the day
belonged to your father
rhaegar targaryen he would end up
wearing the same armor he would die in
it was gleaming black with the
three-headed dragon of his house
wrought in rubies on the breast scarlet
silk streamed behind him when he
rode and it seemed no lance could touch
him brandon stark fell to him
and bronjeon royce and even the splendid
sir arthur dane
the sword of the morning rhaegar was
unstoppable
and that's because he knew that he must
win if he wanted things to unfold the
way they did
as soon as he won rhaegar did not go to
his wife elia martell
instead he laid the queen of beauty's
flowers in lyanna's lap
i can still see it now says helen reed
it was a crown of winter roses
as blue as frost but rhaegar had set all
of this in motion
long before this one day rhaegar found
something in his scrolls that changed
him forever
no one knew what it might have been only
that the boy
suddenly appeared early one morning in
the yard as the knights were donning
their steel
he walked over to sir willem dary the
master at arms and said
i will require sword and armor it seems
i must be a warrior
from this day forward your father knew
many sacrifices would have to be made
this is when your father became obsessed
there was a prophecy he wanted to
fulfill
he became convinced that it would be his
own son who would do it
rhaegar believed his son would be the
prince who was promised
the song of ice and fire this is what
drove him to seek out your mother lyanna
she fell in love with him the very day
they met it wasn't long after this when
they both vanished
we had found your mother in dorne and
what rhaegar would name
the tower of joy your mother laid there
in a bed soaked with blood
the fever had taken her strength and her
voice was faint as a whisper
but she told eddard everything he swore
he would die with her secret and he did
i found eddard still holding her body
silent with grief i had taken her hand
from his
otherwise he would have stayed right
there at her bedside forever
john holds his hand over his mouth while
shaking his head in disbelief
everything has happened for a reason
says helen reed
there is a reason you're here with me
now jon snow
there is a reason bran gave you the
little bit of information he did
when he did john says what do you mean
by that
helen reed stops walking he then sets
his hand on john's shoulder and says
bran knew what would happen once that
information got out
bran knew how that would affect daenerys
targaryen
he had seen it in his visions since he
was still a boy
jon looks stunned as he realizes what
helen reed is about to say
the scene ends right after helen reed
finishes by saying
bran knew daenerys would burn down
king's landing yet he did nothing to
stop it
bran knew you would be exiled back out
beyond the wall
in the final scene of this episode we
will go down to king's landing we are
back inside the red key
at the beginning of the scene brianna is
standing in front of the hand of the
king's new chambers
tyrion lannister opens his door then
says
would you mind stepping inside for a
moment i would like to ask you something
before
i leave when brienne enters the chambers
she says
how may i be of service my lord he
offers her a seat
before taking one himself brienne sits
down as tyrion says
samwell and i recently spoke he said you
were with him
when king bran was displaying some
rather odd behavior
i was hoping you could tell me what you
thought or how you felt about it
before i go speaking with our king well
he was acting a bit different than usual
i suppose
says brienne at first he would not
answer his door
even after i knocked louder and louder
but i thought maybe he just did not hear
me
it was what happened inside of his
chambers that really struck me as odd
sam handed him a book about the legends
of the long night
king bran just sat there staring at it
as he ran his fingers over the drawing
of some horrible looking creature that
was on the front of it
he looked almost as if he was mesmerized
by it
then out of nowhere he throws the book
into the fire
then says sam and i were dismissed now i
know i haven't known him for that long
but i have never seen him act like that
before our king has seen a lot
and knows a lot there's no doubt about
that says tyrion
he has witnessed all of westeros's
violent history
i know i would not want to experience
the effects that would have on someone
anyways i want to thank you sir brianne
i am on my way to speak to king brynn
now
i will walk with you says brienne as
they stand up and head for the door
they suddenly hear the sound of a very
unsettling
frantic scream brienne lays her hand on
the hilt of her sword then
says it sounded like it came from
outside my lord
they run across the room then look out
the window
they can see someone standing below the
red keep with their hand over their
mouth
in shock brienne and tyrion leave his
chambers
then rush down the stairs sir davos runs
across the hall to join them
did you hear that scream says davos yes
it came from outside says tyrion
davos follows them down more stairs then
across the throne room
when they shove open the doors there is
already a crowd
gathered around outside everyone looks
stunned
100 yards in front of them there are
about 30 people standing around in a
circle
all looking down at the ground there are
more standing off to the side
looking up into the sky at the red keep
samwell then emerges from the crowd who
has gathered in a circle
he looks like he has been shaken up all
of the color has left his face
as he begins walking over to them he
wretches up some of his dinner onto the
ground
brienne tyrion and davos all look at
each other
wondering what's happened they slowly
start walking over by the crowd gathered
around
when sam notices them he walks over to
tyrion
lays his hand on his shoulder and says i
am so sorry this happened my lord
before walking away with his head down
as they get closer to the crowd
brienne begins shoving some of them
aside only then
are they able to see what has happened
sir brawn
is laying on the ground dead surrounded
by his own blood and bone
this is when tyrion drops down to one
knee shocked
he looks around at everyone gathered
outside wondering how this could have
happened
davos says i will go find some help
before he runs off
brienne still has her hand on her sword
while she looks for anyone who could
have saw something
raidus tyrion stands back up he notices
everyone is now looking up at the red
key as he follows their eyes up along
the castle
all he can see is the balcony to the
king's chambers
the episode ends as we hear low voices
say
he fell he was shoved he fell
he was shoved i saw it with my own eyes
[Music]
so
so
you